جديد سلطان الطرب بعد وجع الرحيل مسلسل
الانتقام مستمر بين شاكيرا وبيكيه بريتني
سبيرز تطالب احترام بخصوصياتها والمزيد من
غرائب اسبوع الموضه في باريس اليكم
الابراز الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
توجه سلطان الطرب جورج وسوف بالشكر لمن
وقف الى جانبه ووساه بفقدان نجله واعتذر
بحسب بيان صادر عن المكتبه عن الغاء
مشاركته في المناسبات والحفلات التي كانت
مقررات في شهرين بسبب الظروف التي يمر بها
على ان يستانف نشاطه الفني بحلول اواخر
الشهر المقبل وقبل كل شيء قال سلطان الطرب
انه سيكون له موعد مع اغنيه لابنه الراحل
لان الاغنيه عند ابو وديع اصدق تعبير عن
وجعه بحسب نص البيان وكان تركي ال الشيخ
رئيس مجلس اداره هيئه الترفيه السعوديه قد
نشر عبر حسابه الرسمي على تويتر صور
وفيديو لاستقباله لسلطان الطرب معلقا عليه
بالقول مع وديع الغالي واعاد جورج وسوف
نشر مقطع الفيديو في تغريده قال فيها في
ذلك العامله غمرت عائلتنا خليتني اشعر انه
لسه الدنيا بخير بالرغم من اسعدتها
وفي السعوديه وبعد ليله جوائز صنع الترفيه
اعلن موسم الرياض عن انتهاء فعالياته
للعام 2022 واطلاق تقويم الرياض الذي
سيتضمن فعاليات متنوعه في العاصمه على
مدار العام كما احيا مغني الاوبرا
الايطالي اندريا بوتشيلي حفلا وصف بالمبهر
في قاعه المرايا بالعلا وشركته في الحفل
السوداني الرومانيه كريستينا بساريو
[موسيقى]
عالميا وبعد اغنيه شاكيرا التي وصفت
باغنيه الانتقام نشر اللاعب الاسباني
السابق لنادي برشلونه
عالميا ايضا طالبت نجمه البوت الامريكيه
بريتني سبيرز معجبيها باحترام خصوصيتها
وذلك بعد ما زالت الشرطه منزلها بناء على
مكالمات هاتفيه ابدو فيها قلقهم عليها بعد
حذف حسابها على انستغرام ما دفع سبيرز الى
اصدار بيان عبر حسابها الرسمي على تويتر
اعتبرت فيه ما حدث انتهاكا لخصوصيتها
وطلبتهم باحترام هذه الخصوصيه للمضي قدما
بحسب تعبيرها
واخيرا تستمر غرائب اسبوع الموضه في باريس
حيث ابهرت مغنيه الراب الامريكيه دوجا
المشاهدين خلال احدث عروض ازياء كابريلي
باطلاله مثيره غضب فيها اللون الاحمر
جسدها بالكامل وروسيا بثلاثين الف قطعه
كريستال ووصفت فنانه المكياج الاطلاله
مزينه برؤوس حيوانات مزيفه مذهله في
واقعيتها ومستوحها من جحيم دانتي كما قلبت
علامه الازياء فيكتور اندرويد الموضه
راسنا على عقب حرفيا خلال العرض مجموعتها
لربيع والسيف 2003 حينما صارت العارضات
على المدرج بفساتين مقلوبه بجميع
الاتجاهات واشتاحه صور العروض مواقع
التواصل ووصف العرض بالغريب والمجنون